et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jérôme Guedj bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous députés de
l'Essonne porte-parole du Parti
socialiste on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous on va
évidemment parler de ce premier mail et
cortège hier marqué par des violences à
Paris à Nantes à Lyon à Angers ou encore
à Rennes 108 policiers blessés Gérald
Darmanin qui a déploré hier qu'une
partie de la classe politique ne
condamne pas ses violences visant
notamment la gauche et l'extrême gauche
est-ce que vous condamnez fermement
évidemment moi je
soutiens évidemment à chaque fois les
forces de l'ordre quand elles sont
prises à partie par nos mollets des
crétins des cérébrés les Black Blocs
sont les idiots utiles de l'opposition à
cette réforme des retraites la preuve
c'est qu'on parle d'emblée au lieu de
parler de l'ampleur de la mobilisation
on va parler de ceux qui viennent qui
viennent pour casser pour casser du flic
pour casser des biens publics ou des
biens privés donc aucune complaisance
aucune tolérance pour pour cela et donc
moi je condamne simplement c'est c'est
un peu cousu de fil blanc aussi de la
part du gouvernement de venir constater
que un tel ou un tel n'a pas n'a pas
condamné moi je veux pas faire de
polémique sur le sujet mais je mets
quand même dans le débat public et mon
collègue sénateur Jérôme Durand ça fait
une immersion intéressante à
l'invitation de de Gérald Darmanin je
veux qu'on est dans ce pays un débat
public sur les conditions du maintien de
l'ordre parce que sur un point précis ça
faisait plusieurs jours qu'on nous dit
il va y avoir 1000 ou 2000 Black Blocs
présents dans ces manifestations et ils
ont bien été là donc moi je pose aussi
la question de l'efficacité de la
prévention de la détection du repérage
en amont et de la manière de contenir
ces Black Blocs pour éviter qu'à ce
point il puisse être
néfaste au mouvement social je ne sais
pas comment je ne sais pas comment je
constate juste que depuis plusieurs
années je jette pas la pierre uniquement
à ce gouvernement depuis plusieurs
années
notamment depuis la loi travail en 2016
on a la présence de ces de ces casseurs
de ces de ces de ces idiots de ces
crétins dont on est comme on veut en
tous les cas de ceux qui viennent pour
tout autre chose que les motifs des
manifestations et il y a une sorte
d'impuissance dans la doctrine et dans
la technique de maintien de l'ordre
allez contenir et à éviter les images
des astruses qu'on a vu hier et encore
une fois j'exprime toute ma solidarité
chaque fois qu'on voit des policiers qui
sont pris à partie qui reçoivent des
cocktails Molotov ou autre et le
questionnement sur la doctrine de du
maintien de l'ordre il est sur cette
efficacité là et puis plus largement
parce qu'il faut pas non plus éluder ce
qui malheureusement peut aussi exister
et on a vu aussi des images qui sont
problématiques de de force de l'ordre
qui épuisait harasser et peut-être sans
cape clair
se retrouvent elles-mêmes à participer à
ce climat de tension et parfois de
violences policières
ne sont pas forcément
systémique mais en tous les cas elles
sont liées à la doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre au
nassage ou à l'utilisation de certains
de certains armements qui sont une
anomalie française dans la scène
européenne de la doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre il y a la problématique du de la
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre mais
vous parlez d'action préventive le
problème c'est que l'arsenal juridique
n'existe pas et si la loi venait à
changer on entendrait partout dire que
le la France ne respecte plus les droits
de l'homme va beaucoup trop loin en la
matière qu'est-ce qui peut être fait sur
ce sur ce point précis en tous les cas
je veux qu'on ait ce débat là il y a une
sorte de tabou français
il y a une sorte de tabou à avoir un
questionnement sur l'efficacité du
maintien de l'ordre on nous dit c'est
comme ça circuler
au-delà du maintien de l'ordre il y a
aussi une problématique d'ordre
juridique en tous les cas dans une
manifestation quand vous avez des
attroupements qui se s'organisent qui
sont repérés etc je pense que il y a un
cadre juridique qui permet aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il intervenir je vous dis
pas d'aller arrêter les gens au moment
où ils partent de chez eux en amont quoi
que dans certaines situations je rêvais
on a été capable de faire des choses je
pense notamment hooliganisme dans les
stades où on a été capable quand des
gens je parle de gens qui ont déjà été
condamnés qui ont déjà été
identifiés par la justice on a été
capable d'avoir des mesures préventives
sur le terrain de la violence dans les
stades
qui sont des enceintes privées je
comprends pas
donc on fait quoi donc on achète la
question qu'on à chaque à chaque moment
on va passer plus de temps à débat que
vous regardez ce qu'on fait un peu
députés est-ce que vous en tant que moi
je suis un républicain je suis un
républicain conséquent et donc quand
j'ai un problème de maintien de l'ordre
avec des gens qui délibérément viennent
pourrir des un mouvement social je me
dis qu'il faut qu'on règle ce problème
là mais je le ferai pas en passant par
dessus bord les libertés publiques et
les abus éventuels qui peuvent être fait
mais attendez cette ligne de crête pour
l'instant personne ne la recherche je
pense que c'est un débat il y a pas de
débat interdit
je le redis quand on a passé déjà
beaucoup de temps à parler de ceux qui
sont venus pourrir ces manifestations
alors que ces manifs ont été quand même
un grand succès mais vous dites ce sont
les
idiot utiles du gouvernement ça veut
dire que vous craignez que c'est violent
ça faiblissent le mouvement les souffles
évidemment quand on a ces images
désastreuses amplifiées regarder et
c'est normal de les de les regarder on
passe plus de temps à les évoquer et
puis il y a un effet un peu repoussoir
évidemment et je le redis sur lesquels
enfin sur lequel cet effet parfois le
gouvernement joue et surjoue rien que
cette mise en cause permanente en disant
ah vous n'avez pas condamné c'est donc
que vous êtes des complaisants je veux
dire ça suffit je veux dire voilà c'est
j'ai presque dit j'ai failli dire que
c'était de bonne guerre de la part d'un
ministre de l'intérieur mais là quand
même c'est avec des gros sabots mais
monsieur Darmanin est assez coutumier
des gros sabots 2,3 millions de
manifestants selon la CGT près de 800
000 selon le ministère de l'intérieur
alors c'est pas le raz-de-ma désespéré
par les syndicats vous êtes déçus vous
plaisantez on comparons avec des
premiers mais c'est 7 à 10 fois plus que
les 1er mai habituels la dernière fois
qui a eu un premier mythe cette ampleur
c'était le premier mai 2002 dans
l'entre-deux tours très particuliers de
l'élection présidentielle avec Marine Le
Pen avec Jean-Marie Le Pen que les
premiers mai soient unitaire de la part
des dessins mais en tous les cas c'est
une 13e journée de mobilisation
réussie il faut le mettre au crédit de
l'Inter syndical en effet de cette
dimension unitaire et qui atteste d'une
chose qui atteste de la permanence et de
la profondeur dans le pays du rejet de
cette réforme de retraite tous ceux qui
pensaient que on allait pouvoir passer à
autre chose tourner la page et c'était
l'ambition des fumeuses 100 jours
présentés par Elisabeth borne la semaine
dernière d'ailleurs c'était assez
symptomatique elle a pas eu un mot sur
la question des retraites dans son
allocution ils veulent jouer une sorte
d'amnésie de résignation de d'oubli non
là ce que nous dit le mouvement ce que
continue à dire les sondages et
n'importe quelle discussion dans une
famille ou au boulot c'est que les gens
n'oublieront pas ça doit être le
sparadrap du capitaine Haddock le boulet
de ce gouvernement parce que il s'est
entêté la protestation ne se dément pas
et que d'une manière ou d'une autre il y
aura remise en cause de cette réforme
d'une manière ou d'une autre de quelle
manière comment est-ce qu'on rebondit
comment est-ce que le mouvement peuvent
se poursuivre aujourd'hui alors il y a
les canaux juridiques on attend demain
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
sur la deuxième album un référendum
d'initiative partagée
le Conseil constitutionnel à des arcanes
mystérieuses et et complexe à décrypter
une demande a été faite on verra si elle
a validé c'est un chemin compliqué la
mise en oeuvre du référendum
d'initiative partagée mais ça atteste du
fait que on a essayé d'user de tous les
outils somme toute assez réduits dans ce
parlementarisme on va voir la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel le rip a été
fait d'une certaine manière en 2008 pour
ne jamais être mise en oeuvre ou alors
dans des conditions très très
compliquées donc on va voir on a une
proposition de loi qui viendra à
l'Assemblée nationale début juin de
d'abrogation tout ça nous permet de
maintenir dans tous les cas moi je
l'écociné avec mes collègues du groupe
socialiste en tout cas elle va nous
permettre à nouveau d'avoir le débat à
l'Assemblée nationale et de poser la
question à toutes celles et ceux qui se
sont opposés à cette réforme et je pense
notamment aux républicains en leur
disant là vous avez la possibilité
d'incarner votre vote ou en tous les cas
votre rejet vous n'avez pas pu le faire
parce que le 49-3 a été dégainé là vous
avez l'occasion de le fermer je vous ai
dit que j'étais un républicain
conséquent je suis lucide aussi je sais
que c'est un chemin compliqué
puisqu’après un vote à l'Assemblée
nationale il faudrait aller au Sénat et
on connaît là ça passe pas conservateur
du Sénat sur cet aspect des choses mais
encore une fois
juridique mais aujourd'hui nous sommes
essentiellement sur le terrain politique
c'est-à-dire ce gouvernement est dans
une impasse à gouverner et on le voit
bien dans les difficultés à élargir la
majorité car Elizabeth borne il est dans
une impasse à convaincre les Français
parce que il ne le croient plus voilà il
a vu les mensonges les pipos les
approximations l'entêtement la brutalité
démocratique la séquence a été
désastreuse pour les gouvernements il y
avait une impasse politique qui pouvait
être surmontée au lendemain des
élections législatives avec la
construction d'une nouvelle méthode de
travail c'est tout le contraire qui
s'est passé et donc aujourd'hui on est
vraiment sur le terrain politique et ça
doit continuer sur le terrain politique
et la balle est dans le courant si vous
n'êtes pas dans une impasse pour faire
échouer cette réforme des retraites
est-ce que maintenant c'est pas trop
tard mais ce n'est jamais trop tard
c'est pas parce qu'une loi est votée
qu'on peut pas continuer à ici opposer
moi je compte il y a plein de lois qui
sont dans droit positif comme on dit en
France avec lesquels je ne suis pas
d'accord et pour lesquels je veux mener
une opposition démocratique pour lequel
le rendez-vous ça s'appelle l'alternance
démocratique mais pour que l'alternance
démocratique elle se construisent en
connaissance de cause il faut maintenir
vivace le souvenir de ce qui s'est passé
dans cette réforme des retraites à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu un mouvement
social d'ampleur dans ce pays il y a eu
d'une certaine manière une réplique
politique qui a suivi après les grèves
de 1995 il y a eu la victoire de Lionel
Jospin en 1997 après les grèves de 2010
il y a eu la victoire de la gauche en
2012 à chaque fois c'était sur des
questions relatives aux retraites vous
reviendrez dessus si vous avez de
pouvoir on a entendu ça dans la
précédente réforme et vous n'êtes pas
revenu sur la réforme de français moi
j'étais pas au responsabilités je vous
dis une chose c'est que à minima nous
reviendrons sur les sur les 64 ans pour
revenir au 62 ans parce que on peut pas
avoir fait la démonstration du caractère
injuste et inutile de cette réforme et
et ne pas le remettre en question le
moment le moment venu donc et il faudra
par ailleurs un vrai débats vous êtes
passé à 43 annuités il faudra un vrai
débrouille moi je le regrette si vous me
posez la question moi j'ai j'ai pas voté
cette allongement des cotisations à
l'époque où j'étais où j'étais
parlementaire et je pense que sur la
question des retraites qui est
identitaire gérer dans l'identité
républicaine dans l'adhésion à un
certain modèle social je pense qu'on
peut faire autrement plutôt que de céder
à la facilité qui a été celle du
gouvernement intéressantes c'est les
mouvements sociaux de 95 et 2010 deux
ans après l'alternance a eu lieu deux
ans après là on a 4 ans avant la
prochaine présidentielle est-ce que si
vous avez raison 4 ans c'est très long
comment on fait pour pour vivre cet
impact politique et là et maintenir
cette espèce de continuum pendant 4 ans
vous avez raison mais l'impasse
politique il faut quand même rendre à
César ce qui est à saint-zar à César
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui est dans
l'impasse je vais vous poser la question
de cet impact politique la seule
solution c'est de c'est de retirer le
texte là on l'espèce il son
[Musique]
d'autres journées de manifestation ou
est-ce que désormais ça ne sert plus à
rien et vous souhaitez d'autres formes
de contestation est-ce que par exemple
il faut perturber des événements des
matchs de foot le Festival de Cannes
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à ça la
manifestation la mobilisation sociale
elle est dans le patrimoine social de ce
pays et donc là où les syndicats
l'intersyndical et parfois les
organisations politiques auront des
propositions à faire moi encore une fois
ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'on
maintienne une pression démocratique
pacifique évidemment sur le gouvernement
pour ne pas cautionner des événements
sportifs et culturels soient perturbés
tout dépend ce qu'on appelle perturbé
avoir une expression
symbolique regardez ce qui s'est passé
samedi au Stade de France l'espèce
d'hystérie securitaire dans lequel la
crainte d'une expression somme toute
symbolique je vais dire qu'un président
se fasse siffler ou que des cartons
rouges soient arborés dans une enceinte
sportive je vois pas en quoi c'est
attentatoires à y compris l'organisation
de l'événement et il a fallu non mais il
a fallu mais regardez le niveau
d'hystérie dans lequel on a été de la
part du gouvernement avec un président
de la République obligé de de d'être
présent d'une certaine manière en
catimini avec l'image qui était pas
présente dans dans le stade enfin j'ai
un moment il faut assumer quand on est
président de la République si on est
droit dans ses bottes on prend des
décisions on les assume et se faire
siffler encore une fois pardon mais
c'est ça participe du jeu démocratique
voilà et il y a pas en avoir peur
sur la suite Laurent Berger dit qu'il se
rendra à Matignon quand Elisabeth borne
l'invitera alors sous condition et en
disant que la confiance n'est pas là
mais est-ce qu'il a raison d'accepter
l'invitation d'abord il est souverain
dans son organisation syndicale et moi
j'ai jamais considéré qui aurait une
rupture advitable eternam due la
discussion et du dialogue simplement on
peut pas passer crème pardonnez-moi à
l'expression et donc si il faut par une
période on va dire de décence
indiqué au gouvernement que encore une
fois on n'a pas oublié je pense que
c'est ça aussi qui alimente le mouvement
social là le gouvernement a voulu ouvrir
des chantiers mais faut pas oublier que
ces chantiers en eux-mêmes ils sont à
nouveau problématique moi je suis frappé
par le fait qu'Elizabeth borne nous est
dit on va rentrer dans une période
d'apaisement mais les sujets qui sont
mis sur la table la réforme du lycée
professionnel
France travail et conditionné le RSA à
une période d'activité obligatoire
et les autres sujets qui ont été mis sur
la table sont pas des sujets qui sont
super consensuels donc j'attendrai
vraiment spécifique avec le Gouvernement
sur ce sujet sur la loi travail sur la
loi pleine emploi on a toujours indiqué
que nous travaillons stylo à la main sur
les propositions mais simplement
pardonnez-moi l'expression mes chats
échaudé
craint l'eau froide depuis juillet
dernier et le discours de politique
générale d'Elisabeth borne ça pas du
tout été la pratique moi je le vois sur
des textes sur lequel je travaillais je
pense au sujet relatif aux
vieillissement de la population et bien
vivre c'était le gouvernement tout seul
qui travaille et qui impose son
calendrier et c'est toute petite
mesurettes et on l'a vu sur bien des
sujets un mot une question sur le
l'agence de notation Fitch qui a dégradé
le la note de la France et qui doute de
la capacité d'Emmanuel Macron a
poursuivre la réforme et qui dit que la
poursuite de la contestation du
mouvement social affaiblit le pays
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je pense
que les agences de notation celle là en
l'occurrence rend dommage d'une certaine
manière au mouvement au mouvement social
la dégradation de la note c'est une
inquiétude libérale sur le fait que les
mesures ne sont pas assez dures ne vont
pas assez loin et ne produisent pas des
effets de
cure si j'ose dire suffisamment rapide
moi j'ai jamais été un fan de ces
agences de notation j'ai été président
d'un département et je subissais la
notation vous savez vous savez aussi que
c'est jugé qui nous juger ça peut avoir
aussi un impact sur les finances
publiques du pays oui mais notamment sur
la route du taux d'intérêt
l'État français
il y a des gens voilà un système
financarisé qui dit pour que je vous
donne une bonne note il faut que vous
soyez encore plus dur il faut que vous
réduisiez les dépenses sociales il faut
que vous réduisiez le
périmètre d'intervention des services
publics et à ce moment-là vous serez
dans un bon canal libéral et je vous
donnerai des bonnes notes donc il y a
aussi une capacité assez extraire à ça
il y a toujours une part de comment dire
de de souveraineté et d'indépendance je
fais un parallèle à l'époque nous on en
avait marre de se faire noter par ces
organismes on a créé l'agence des
finances locales alors c'est un sujet
dont les sénateurs ont beaucoup débattu
c'est à dire un moment donné de s'unir
pour être en capacité d'emprunter
ensemble et avoir une force de frappe
donc un moment donné il faut aussi en
capacité de s'extraire de cette doxa qui
nous dit il y a pas de theres non
alternative le fameux
mantra taschien qui nous dit que hormis
la baisse des dépenses sociales ou des
dépenses publiques il y a pas de
solution alternative le niveau le niveau
d'endettement du pays en fait 3000
milliards de de dettes 110% du PIB
est-ce que est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
peut encore se permettre de d'accroître
les déficits mais en tous les cas on
peut se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi on en est arrivé à ce niveau de
déficit enfin là dans la doxa libérale
personne ne pose jamais la question de
pourquoi la baisse des impôts qui a été
décidé ces quatre ou cinq dernières
années à elle-même alimenter le déficit
le fameux ruissellement augmenter les
impôts en tous les cas questionner
l'efficacité des baisses d'impôts ou des
exonérations de cotisations qui ont été
mises en oeuvre c'est jamais questionner
c'est-à-dire quand on a des exonérations
de cotisation sociale on nous dit ah bah
c'est absolument indispensable pour
l'emploi moi je viens de lancer avec la
mission d'évaluation des comptes de la
Sécurité sociale à l'Assemblée nationale
avec un député Renaissance Marc ferrachi
une mission pour évaluer l'efficacité
des exonérations de cotisation sociale
parce qu'on sait bien que certaines sont
totalement inutiles et impactent
l'équilibre des finances publiques on va
te parler du PS et de la nuque pour
terminer marine tondeuillier la chef
d'Europe Écologie les verres a dit une
nouvelle fois une énième fois j'ai envie
de dire qu'il n'y aura pas de liste
commune aux européennes vous le
regrettez oui je le regrette par
principe chacun s'exprime avec son
histoire sa sensibilité mais nous sommes
aujourd'hui dépositaire de ce qu'est la
nuque c'est à dire une espérance qui a
été levée il y a presque un an jour pour
jour en mai 2022 au lendemain l'élection
présidentielle ce rassemblement de la
gauche et des écolog était un fait
inédit depuis des années dans l'histoire
politique du pays et moi je croise
encore aujourd'hui des électeurs qui
nous disent vous avez bien fait mais ne
lâchez pas voilà donc après il y a des
mouvements centrifuges je les entends
bien la question des européennes en fait
partie mais au moins qu'on vérifie si
nous avons des accords ou des désaccords
plutôt que d'être sur une position de
principe et donc moi vous y croyez je
serai unitaire pour deux pour trois pour
cinq pour dix et qu'à chaque fois qu'on
a l'occasion de garder ce cadre commun
de le préserver pour la suite des
opérations parce que l'alternance et
l'alternative le moment venu ne pourra
se construire que dans le cadre du
rassemblement de la gauche et des
écologistes en le faisant évoluer
évidemment et donc moi vous savez quoi
je n'ai pas envie au soir des élections
européennes d'avoir cette image
désastreuse je la visualise déjà d'avoir
le rassemblement national en tête suivi
probablement de renaissance les deux au
dessus de 20% et pourquoi pas plus et
puis un gros trou entre les deux et puis
une un éclatement une kyrielle vous
savez de ces barres entre Europe
Écologie Les Verts le PS les communistes
les insoumis etc si cette image là
s'imprime au soir des élections
européennes alors plein de gens vont se
dire mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
l'image qu'on a eu aux dernières
européennes en fait ce que vous êtes en
train d'écrire je suis absolument
d'accord et on a tourné la page de ces
divisions mortifères à gauche à
l'occasion des élections législatives en
construisant rapidement un contrat de
coalition c'est pour ça que moi je
plaide pour qu'on travaille sur le fond
sur le fond là chacune Olivier fort a
proposé de ce réunir dans le cadre d'une
agora en stylo à la main sur les
questions notamment européennes et moi
je souhaite qu'on le fasse sur tous les
autres sujets moi l'horizon 2027 c'est
construire un contrat de coalition qu'on
n'a pas élaboré en 13 jours et 13 nuits
juste avant qu'on a pris le temps à
partir de ce qu'est la corne UPS de 2022
d'enrichir d'amender de faire évoluer
mais de travailler Montaigne disait il
faut se limer les cervelles dans la
discussion euh les uns les autres et ben
continuons à le faire fermer en 2027
alors vous désignez votre candidat
d'abord chaque chose en son temps mais
moi je l'ai déjà dit dès le début du
mois de janvier j'avais indiqué une fois
qu'on a fait ce travail sincère en
gardant la nups et malheur à celui ou à
celle qui va faire péter le cadre de la
nupes mais en gardant ce cadre là en
ayant une démarche sincère en
travaillant sur le fond de chacune des
propositions la question sociale la
question écologique les questions
fiscales les questions républicaines les
questions internationales enfin enrichir
le programme et et le compléter on
construit ce contrat de coalition pour
les élections législatives de 2027 parce
que il faut qu'on sort tous du
crétinisme présidentiel dans lequel on
est en disant il y a un homme ou une
femme présidentielle construisons le
programme des législatives on a compris
qu'il y a pas de politique possible si
on a pas une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale donc on construit ce contrat
de coalition et après on va chercher
celui ou celle qui peut l'incarner et je
le redis je vois pas d'autre solution
qu'une primaire pas à l'ancienne
puisqu'à l'ancienne les primaires
c'était problématiques parce qu'on
tranchait à la fois la ligne et la
personne là quasiment personne n'est
favorable parce que pour l'instant tout
le monde a en tête les précédentes
primaires où ont tranché à la fois une
ligne et une personne si on s'est mis
d'accord sur un contrat de coalition on
a donc une ligne et après on choisit le
meilleur ou la meilleure pour l'incarner
et on aura assez coté des compétiteurs
qui le jour le moment venu soutiendront
malheur à celui qui cassera le cadre de
la nuque est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le
paradoxe c'est pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui essaye de casser lui-même la nuque
qu'il a créé en tous les cas elle ne
veut plus de lui en fait si vous aviez
aujourd'hui à faire une primaire pour
désigner votre candidat à gauche on est
d'accord c'est pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui sortirait du chapeau si il décidait
d'être candidat et qu'il était retenu
par la majorité des électeurs de gauche
il deviendra à ce moment-là notre
candidat mais il faut accepter ce cadre
de la dispute apaisée ce cadre
démocratique autour d'un programme moi
ce qui m'intéresse le plus avant parler
de la primaire avant de parler de la
présidentielle c'est que on se mette en
ordre de bataille pour on le fait dans
le travail parlementaire et c'est très
heureux là je vais vous quitter pour
rejoindre l'inter-groupe de la nupes qui
se réunit toutes les semaines on se
parle on affine nos propositions la
manière de nous opposer etc donc ça
c'est déjà un acquis mais élargissons-le
dans la préparation de l'alternative
merci Jérôme merci à vous merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité la Une de
Ouest-France Stéphane mobilisation du
1er mai la rue maintient la pression
merci Stéphane merci Jérôme